Also, I am aware
today of the popularity of Jordan Bardella,
which is 1 kind of media product.
I say,
he is a member of the European Parliament,
Jordan Bardella,
he filed twenty-one amandements
within 4 years of mandate.
To give you 1 point of comparison,
I put some
filed overtrois-mille-deux-cent-soixante.
So today you have 1 guy who speaks well,
so that's good, eh,
it comes uh.
Pavané uh.
On TV,
but who today does nothing for the French,
and attacks the European Parliament,
the right to abortion,
who votes uh.
All uh. Uh.
The uh.
Especially uh.
The measures most favorable to the richest,
against the taxation of super profits by companies
agri-food companies
that gobble up and drive up prices.
That's right,
Jordan Bardella.
So I'm going to fight it with arguments
substantive policies.